[Music]
I didn't start with running 100K I
didn't start with ice cold bars every
day last showers every day cold showers
every day I didn't start with reading 10
most of the book I started with
go for a run okay I'm getting further in
my running now I can incorporate eating
well
the seating world's actually really
helping me and it was just like this
incremental increase in
doing the more uncomfortable things so
when that became comfortable I just did
the next thing and then all of a sudden
I'm you know beating down marathons
since it started out as a external you
know lose weight but what I found when I
was trying to do that was this feeling
of achievement by getting the next run
by getting the next run and all of a
sudden I'm you know doing these long
runs and I'm feeling this excitement
about how far I can push myself now it's
got nothing to do with losing weight the
weight is a byproduct of now me being
happy and me being content with what I'm
doing